[Music]
so you've been here for a little while
for years right it's time to send you on
a little business trip this weekend
three days Barcelona I'm going to Spain
well your energy would be perfect for
this
what do you mean my energy your energy
your drive your ambition where are you
putting them in quotes because I mean
vagina anyway have fun in Barcelona bye
so great I could totally take the time
off and I'm freelance so I'm totes avail
guys this is an important work trip for
me you're not coming yeah go tell room
we can do whatever the heck we want yeah
I just didn't know it was two beds guys
the DJ he's hot he's amazing Mike he's
like a pro con - man I'm leo listening
you I'm Harper are you staying for
[Applause]
now the police I'm in Ibiza
we had like a real connection listen to
me yo man vos isn't Ibiza tonight I
can't just fly to a visa I have a very
important meeting here tomorrow night
this is destiny
some people land on the moon others cure
diseases you smash this DJ yeah actually
that was really impressive in a good
point if this is as good as this trip
gets this is pretty good I can't still
think about you this could be my last
chance to ever see him again
you know what might give a [ __ ] meter is
at zero so we're gonna party all night
[Applause]
hotel rooms are backlight nightmares
there's like residual jizz everywhere
okay I have to sweat out this juicy
right
[Music]
[Applause]
you